both of these images are groundbreaking
and they're connected on the Left you've
got the world through Yul Brynner's eyes
in West world be 1973 movie where he
plays a robot cowboy this is not a
spoiler I mean he's a robot on the
poster and if you've seen the HBO series
you know that everything is a robot it's
this pixelated robots eye view that gave
birth to CGI computer-generated imagery
but the technique and idea did not come
from Hollywood it came from a bit
further away this is a picture of Mars
the CGI in the original Westworld was
groundbreaking so now we're going to see
if we can get our computer graphics team
to replicate it oh yeah I'm done takes
like two clicks but in the early 1970s
computers this powerful were
non-existent and digital images were
rare these title swirls in 1958 vertigo
were sort of computer-generated imagery
the designer repurposed in m5
anti-aircraft guns mechanical computer
to help draw these intricate patterns
other experiments were digital but they
were basically art films after all non
CGI effects could generate stunning
results
[Music]
still Westworld creator michael crichton
wanted to create a robots point of view
hollywood hadn't done it yet but nasa
had NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory
launched Mariner 4 it was the first
flyby of Mars and it transmitted back
the first up-close photographs of the
planet the method it used to get those
images back to earth was important for
two reasons it shaped what a digital
picture should look like and it gave
technical guidance for the west-world
CGI the pictures were sent back as
numbers 240,000 bits of binary code
representing the shading the forty
thousand dots that will finally make up
the first picture a complex system of
computers is required to convert these
numbers into pictures some workers
decide to hand make their own picture of
Mars by hating the numbers yes our first
up-close picture of Mars it was a
paint-by-numbers ultimately the computer
generated images ended up looking like
these in the 1973 cover story of
American cinematographer Westworld
designer john whitney jr wrote that the
scanning digitizing methods employed by
Jet Propulsion Laboratory on their
Mariner Mars flybys could be used here
but using the rare computer at the lab
would have cost 100 grand
they found a private company to
basically copy the Jet Propulsion labs
methods to scan production footage frame
by frame and convert it to numerical
information which would then be played
back on a special machine
INRI recording to make the perfect robot
vision the designers use data that
created an image with 3,600 squares and
they had to get creative to make sure
the cgi action came through clearly
actors wore clothing to contrast with
the background here's one wearing white
clothing and makeup they also increased
the contrast in post-production and
though it took a full minute to scan
each frame or about eight hours for a 10
second sequence the CGI worked
Hollywood couldn't have sorry can you
just stop Hollywood couldn't have come
up with this idea alone it took the Rd
from the five hundred fifty million
dollar Mariner program to inspire
something as fanciful as CGI especially
when practical effects could have gotten
the job done but it was the future
Whitney finished that article for
American cinematographer by saying my
work on Westworld suggested many more
possibilities than we were able to
explore and there are certainly many
others yet to be imagined a so this
edition of almanacs all about big
changes to the movies that came from
outside of Hollywood so if you know of
any other sciency type innovations like
what you just saw that changed movies
let me know in the comments there's a
lot out there however I cannot in this
video without letting you know about
future world it is the sort of Forgotten
sequel to West's world but the CGI is
actually still influential and that's
because it's likely this source of the
first 3d CGI face